ouais ouais ma réunion a été annulée ouais en
train de travailler sur le canapé
quelqu'un a pris mon tapis de yoga Paul Simonon
docteur je vais faire quelque chose d'urine tasse de
noix de coco que vous vérifiez oh oh oh ça
dit Gershwin voit qu'elle pourrait Garver tu
vois oh nous devrions être sœur endroit pour perdre
Simona  GBC ne continuez pas mm-hmm vous savez que
Buffy mettra votre genou ne lâche pas
hein hein c'est sur la bonne voie, nous pourrions seulement savoir que
je vous arrête vous êtes libres les gars oh
nous le sommes donc ça pourrait être Regina faire
un  soufflé pour polir jusqu'à un
possessif Erica dr.  Mehta veut et sa
devise sais que je suis un
garçon d'ordinateur beaucoup plus stupide je ne fais rien
ouais bien sûr es-tu allé ouais arrête arrête
beaucoup P Chine eh bien j'étais en paix
attaché le dikha de ohh
Tori Maura